[音楽]
おい話を業務だめだしてたやん
26歳独身車もう全て発売されるポケットモンスターの最新作ポケットモンスター創造
シールのみんな
予約したから俺あさきお店で予約してきたぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜー
ぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーぜーとを予約した時これを見せて
もらったんだけどこれ知ってるから君
伊豆限って書いてるんだけどこれどうやらポケモンの秘密倶楽部の間衣装らしいんだ
これで私も僕も秘密倶楽部の会員ってことか
さぁづ回路してみよう秘密から打ってもうなんなんだろうねぇ
開けますおおおおすごいそそシールド御三家がかえってやります
でここに会員サイトの東京市
リアルコートが歳になるけどこれは見せられないよ
釣りあるコードを登録して初めて秘密クラブの仲間になれるみたいだから俺は仲間
はずれなんて言えだから早速秘密クラブに入ってくるよ
はいという気でたとし予約墓標秘密クラブに入りだぜというこでご覧くださいこちらが
ポケモン秘密クラブのサイトで進めてくれ肇社長様って書いてあるぜ相手ここが映像部
ですね限定の情報が仕入れるらしいんですけどもこの動画を撮っているときは残念
ながらまだ
映像はないみたい彼とし残念けどみんながきっとロギー
でこれには動画があると思うよなんでこれ
ポケモン日見つければ何でもボックス7月17日に解禁をボケも秘密比べの期待や応援
疑問質問などメッセージを募集してるみたいだな
何マラソンをやっているのかまあソングは会員数を増やして今日も活動中をはせ外飼い
が増えるとプレゼントが貰えるらしいぞ
そして考察分毎週出てくるオーダーについて
メンバーの意見を大募集公開された情報を基にあれこれ考えてみよう
君の考えがサイトに掲載されるかもそしてそしてプレゼント無難と抽選でプレゼントが
もらえるみたいだ
第1回の抽選で当たるプレゼントはこちら尺後マゼンタのスチールブックがもらえる
みたいな旋回不明の外にプレゼント等でぜひ皆さん応募してみてねそう戦に参加します
よし
当たれ
ん
と言うけど私はお店で予約したんですけども予約するお店によって得点が違うみたいで
アニメイトだとアクリルキーホルダー迫宿遷ブックがもらえたり
amazon でも何か貰えるんだほかにもいい音とかイトーヨーカドエディオンゲオ
増進などほんといろんなお店で予約して得点がそれで強いのでみんなはどこのお店で
予約するから
んちょっとれて皆ポケット思ったそうとシールドとても楽しみで
波戸氏はもう
待ってないで歯と歯を見てしまったんだソードシールドの紹介の動画で
波戸氏は見てしまった
そうシールドで
東独ないを止めてしまったそれは何かそうだ今 x
阿部はもう今までのポケモンでは考えられないシステムカート省道路聞いたイマーク
するのは簡単に説明すると
ポケモンが巨大化して強くなる現象のことらしいポケモンが巨大化すると同時に
トレーナー持っているモンスターボールまでも大きくなってしまうそれが
第まあと言うけど波動し私は思ってしまいました
他都市も大 max したい
はいばいいで今日は果たしご覧くださいここにモンスターボールのもととなる素材が
ありますちょっと大きいなんですけどもこれをそのままもんサーバにしてもきっと里樹
の満足する大 max のボールの大きさには至らないと思います私の想像の中では大
max で使われるモンスターボールはもう
的でこのボールのもととなる方に
秦プチ縁を使って肉付けしてって俺がどのトレーナーよりも先に大 max を
やりすぎで悩ま2とに使われた巨大なモンスターボールを作っていきたいとおもいます
イェーガー調子じゃあさっそく作っていくぜ
多分このままどうぞやべぇこれ待ってねこの前とを練習が大バックスちまう頑張れます
から
[音楽]
ファースト貼るのやめとけよ山でソードシールドの障害の動画で見た時のマジ
モンスターボールが混ぜて変え大 max げーよ本当に
こんなサイズの頃じゃなかったよ多分
貸してください
モンスターボールだロードはぽすけ本の
部屋ボケ同じがより快適にするためにきれいな円の形を作っていきます
さあベトベトン敦也 wiki くれちゃうぞ
愛情で一発屋醜態が出来ましたじゃあこれだと言わんとオーダー転がししかできないよ
って言ってここに縁をつけてさらに大きくしていますべとべと雪だってくれ
はいベトベトもいえるクラッ
もうベトベトンいいぞん
ああああああ
ベボベ等なんと思ったんだれぞれぞ
まあ今肉付け何でもあるブーブー大丈夫だと思います
ブースター作目の結果はせなったらしい
そこだああああナイフ f
ああ
あああああやっています
なぜいきなりませんぽうというかめちゃくちゃ昨日同期会まで来てますね
にゃろんをっ
出てるぞ the better
息子へ
[音楽]
はい的でだいたいますとってきてあこれじゃあこれぐらいでいいかなと思います
imax の大サーバたぶんこんなもんだったと思いますね
ねえ国家はモンスターボールの色を作っていきましょう
まずは上半身から上を主要にしていくよ
おにぎりな利用学的我
[音楽]
i 半分のこっち側だけ白にできました
あとは骨のハムは赤にしていきますいやー
じゃいま
できどうぞあるん
ハープーン阻止5000とはーはっはっは赤道直下撮りましたら
航空行きまーす
ぱすーっ
気絶しそう
はいというわけでここまで綺麗なさーーん
サイズががやばすぎるのとかなりでかいですもう一人手に負えません
までもおそらく大マッチのモンスターボールはこれぐらいだと思うんでこのサイズで
間違いないでしょう
あとはボールのあのスイッチの部分をつけます
[音楽]
a これをなここ年作る時はもうモンスターボールになるんじゃないか2
30発送
はーい
カートウェイで両翼把握しました完全にモンスターボールですちょっと肉付けの部分で
かなり形がいびつになったんですけども
もう色は本傷つけなんで完璧に赤と白になっておりますだよエアとし仲間のベトベトン
の力も借りながら2時間かけてようやく作ることができました
見てくれこのサイズかこれが新時代のポケモン
第まあ誘える後輩のポケモントレーナーに一番して子やっ
てくると思うよん
rar
ああああああ
4分
ヨシ子様連れ理系アーロン
ファイラー
ああああああ
ハーイいっ
me
ええええええ
ああああああ
re
強大なポケモー
それだけでいいもう
はいというわけでポケットモンスターソードシールドの発売日は11月の15日予定と
なっておりますそして予約は現在受付中ですのでぜひ皆さんを教務秘密クラブに入会し
て発売を一緒に待ちましょう
[音楽]
car
teame
me
[音楽]
バッハ